I think that you should always just do
like make what you want to see be
mindful that anyone can see what you're
doing so don't be offensive don't just
make a video like bashing out other
people's videos or other projects being
consistent like weekly if you have time
daily because then people can keep up
with you start showing your friends and
family like this is what I'm doing it
doesn't mean you have to just go and get
a Twitter to Facebook me like everyone
watch my stuff like start small and it
can grow and make content that is
enjoyable for audiences but mostly just
be consistent
well generally it's hard to say it
because I'm guilty like chai not to be
awkward and she like animated
that's definitely a two
don't would be so don't make something
for the point like just to make
something you have to make it because
you want to something that you're going
to be proud of I see a lot of
channels that I go to and they don't
have many subscribers but I think it's
because they want an audience and then
to be really
just like pain and general
they're not really making it themselves
because people aren't interested in
watching a video that the person is
making it doesn't even care about
and so that's generally how I feel about
I don't know about the don'ts but the
dues is like what here's the thing I
broke all the rules you know I didn't I
mean it's it's different for me though
because I saw God and put a video put on
YouTube but everyone else its work you
just you just got to work the community
you got to be friendly you got to go out
there and the bottom line is you got to
create content that's interesting and
people want to watch if you don't have
that then you can't do anything but on
top of that then you got to go to
network you gotta you know show it to
other people and it's it's all just work
it's not how I did it but I cheated well
for you to creating do it's fun do you
like as far as
as far as I commenting on that stuff we
open like bring people down just because
you don't like
don't get too involved
I think it's really important to to
connect with people people who like I'm
not that big I'm not big on YouTube like
I'm I'm fairly really low but um 0 there
are people who like say that they love
my stuff you know comments on and
everything I think
you know message them back and say thank
you so much and like you're really
have my god
so I think that's really important as
far as they commenting on other videos
all the time I mean I hate when people
like troll and say like they like have
bad comments and just like everything I
think that's
I'd say look at it and try to see if
it's just purely a spiteful thing or
whether there's something constructive
you can take from it because a lot of
the time there are valid things that
people say that you can learn from
and sort of get an idea of what people
are enjoying
it feels like that for me but maybe I'm
not the right person to ask because i
have like issues with communicating with
people i have social anxiety so like in
real life it's difficult for me to bond
and open up it's easier to me to do that
online so i actually use that line to
have a community and have support and
have friends I'm not that good at making
outside
I have met lots of people who have the
same problem use YouTube parts opening
up and in saying things that you're not
that comfortable
because you're not he kind of awkward
with
so I think this is very common
do I don't know etiquette but I think
it's really important to collaborate and
to try to offer your services to people
like or just collaborate with friends or
it might be something music channel so I
find it's really good idea just to try
to offer to help as many other people in
the community as possible a tip they
don't necessarily have to follow is do
have a lot of information per second
people's attention spans are short cut
between causes and that's a thing on
otherwise good equipment always helped
but it's not necessarily needed they're
just things that would mice that were
there's not really anything that would
create a negative body unless you try to
collect
your channel which has less quality
videos to a channel that has like really
huge quality videos as a video response
because there's displacement you first
no not you first the one aha moment that
I've taken away is that we are
dreadfully small and there's not a
really apparent reason why yet but
that's are still trying to figure out so
we've asked for input from a couple
people they're doing some homework and
looking at our channel to try to figure
out yeah we walked up Freddie long like
a new diagnose why we're not making the
viewership that we should you took our
car he said tweet me later for free debt
and um that's where we're at we that was
his take away I have a different one Oh
every panel every panel we've walked
into I've listened to everything they
say and I just go down like a checklist
done that done that done that doing that
that's in progress and I'm like they're
all checked what am I missing here what
are not working for us that everybody
else seems to be you know
so I haven't figured it out yet I don't
know if it's just we think it's look we
think there is some level of it falls on
the right page at the right minute that
the right person happens to be around
the page who has influence who says oh
that came up on your newsfeed today I'm
going to tweet that for you know 50,000
people it's not to say that talents not
required because like there's there's
like first you have to have a great
video we have to clear the barf then on
top of that you have to get that one
lucky moment because there are great
leaders all over the Internet I think we
don't know but yeah but that's see
definitely something I think I'm taking
away is that you really just have to be
somewhat in the right place at the right
time which is the same as the rest of
the industry that you really there are
opportunities and you need to be
available for opportunities you need to
be capable of grabbing opportunities but
outside of that you have to keep trying
to make opportunities and that's you
know all we can do my takeaway is we
have to collaborate but my takeaway is
there is there are channels out there
who have probably similar numbers of
subscribers to us but they're totally
different human beings subscribe to them
so if we're similar to another channel
you need to work together and those
applicable subscriptions are going to
you know pop over to your channel
because you're doing the same stuff and
you're doing stuff that they love and so
if you work together you'll hopefully be
able to build a lot more a lot more
traffic just because you're working with
other people who have totally different
people on their channel so i don't know
that's that's mine